slip dog is a new album bush and
a very sexy bit of pr of course that uh
the mighty pharrell
he co-wrote do you cover it all songs he
produced the whole album produced the
whole album yes sir
wow now is it true that pharrell he was
the one encouraging you to be a bit more
family-friendly a bit more mainstream
yeah yeah he
made me change certain words i had a
song called so many hoes he made so many
pros
well that certainly toned it down
are pros just prostitutes no they're
professionals
oh i see silly me
the ladies in the video still look quite
like hoes
but they're professionals
they're in a video and then
pharrell is it true that he i mean i'm
sure he enjoyed working with you
but he did have some difficulties
working with you as well
yeah when we were um working on a
particular song called california rome
um stevie wonder had came up to the
studio and pharrell had called a second
hand
contact from being in the studio with me
and he kind of froze he didn't know how
to produce it anymore he was stuck
he was like i might have to explain what
the
yes so pharrell was in an environment
created by snoop
pharrell was no longer the same pharrell
he was he was now someone else
he was not he was not the greatest
producer in the world he wasn't the best
there was just a guy in the room
so was stevie wonder trying to talk to
him stevie wonder was in the mic booth
and you know stevie can't see so stevie
was waiting on some direction
and pharrell wasn't giving me no
direction so steven was just in there
just
i'm like well well stevie farrell said
can you sing this part and then pharrell
said can you play the harmonica so i had
to basically take over
because pharrell was stuck off of space
cookies he was in another place
i was real happy with his work on that
on that track he was happy a couple of
days after
and then you did go to one of those
clubs you went to the ping-pong clubs
we did yes uh we did um in our spare
time
uh but we also shot stills there and i
had a very unfortunate experience
uh with the ping-pong ball what happened
uh uh i was trying to be a you know a
showboat
and i opened up my mouth to pretend to
catch the ball
and and and she called my bluff
[Applause]
it was amazing i'm totally confused
okay so you thought the mtv story was
okay
i'm gonna hear this one yeah off you go
bradley
you tell us what the nice lady did
so you can pay to watch women eject
um various objects out of their uh
uh vaginal cavity
um sort of kites and stuff
ribbons
[Music]
so and the precision with which she
could do it is incredible this one very
talented young woman
and um and so we were all sitting there
in the monkey chow
myself and stu and i was like
this would be a good one todd get this
one wouldn't it be funny if and she was
just like
boom
and i was sick again
nigella you generous creature i know
you're very busy
but you've already made us a lovely gift
i did a cake and i've got the cake here
look forward to seeing it this is the
cake you made i don't know how long you
spent making it
uh there it is
but it looks like [__]
taste it it's delicious one first a
little bit
well you're going straight for the [__]
who does it
i thought i might try that do not cast
the first stone straight for the [__]
look at that
that doesn't work
what a cruel joke we've played on you
thank you
still dry i could eat on but i'll save
some room for nature that's right
that'd be nice if you visit us around
for christmas of course christmas is
coming
it certainly is are you looking forward
to christmas always rio are you really
into christmas no i really am into
christmas
you into christmas i love it
no seriously are you yeah last year
christmas i spent alone
come to mine but nigellas
no so but as a child you find chris was
quite traumatizing
did i yes weren't you in a nativity play
that was christian school on christmas i
would steal the baby jesuses
and the black wise men i tried to create
some sort of coup
in south florida where it would start
a ruckus where and i wrote a letter
the white man is falsely plasticized the
white crispness and i went on and on and
then i replaced the baby jesus with a
ham
you can't argue with that i think i
prefer a ham
i've got admitted nativity nice
and what are you doing for christmas
this year um
not going to my girlfriend's house yeah
because you have quite a young
girlfriend now haven't you
yes you do too girlfriend unlikely
well here in britain
many people will be getting i noticed
there's an open space in the back of
your seat
yes there it is so it's yeah at any
moment christmas could come
yeah we're all living the world of
glamour
well you know sex in the city new york
david doesn't er
i mean maybe on paper it sounds worse
than it is
but is it true you still live in a next
council flat
uh yes yeah yeah well you must be making
quite a lot of money and
gordon has made the houses nice and
cheap well yes and that's
you know and i and the thing is i live
in a flat i bought
six or seven years ago is fine but
except it's
much more unpleasant than it was when i
moved in obviously because i've been
living there but i i sort of
the prospect of the last time i moved
was i think the most stressful day of my
life ever
and i the prospect of moving in is
terrifying now houses are getting
cheaper and cheaper i've got another
excuse not to move
and i actually i hate the fact that i
have to take pride in where i live
i i hate it's all on the television the
whole time everyone's like oh i
you know i couldn't stand this living
room i'd have to change that i'd have to
why do you have to change all these all
you need is a roof heating
a tv and a fridge and you're sorted what
sort of [__] all do you live in
everyone's got to give such a massive
[__] about their domicile
why because it's a nice thing to
surround yourself with if that's
if that's your hobby fine but why is
there so much pressure on me to be
bothered to move and tidy up
and paint the place and worry about that
bit over the cooker that's melting
you see there there are a lot of other
slovenly people out there
and when we get around to it we will
speak
this you've got to give in the celebrity
version of how clean is your house oh
kim and aggie going to come around we
just gotta go
oh my god we wouldn't let them yeah i
mean why would i permit that
why does anyone permit why does anyone
put that apart from they do clean your
house
for free i've never felt my house is so
dirty that i wouldn't mind
public humiliation i mean just
either do it yourself or pay someone
just like no i want it for free and i
don't mind the whole country
thinking i'm a slob you could do a
cartwheel
[Applause]
you're all in proportion you're not
i haven't shaved my penis
why would i do a car would i pick up a
gun i'd just pick up a gun i wouldn't
no no no no no no you wouldn't
because they're firing at you right and
you can't run
because they're shooting head height you
go oh i know i'll do a cartwheel
let them shoot my legs less important
than the head right
pick the gun up crumble because they've
shot my legs
and then you suit their problems
straight away mid cartwheel yeah they're
shooting at me
glasses come on
now i'm shooting at you without your
glasses on i can't i don't know what
have you to do a column
i'll give a thousand pounds to charity
if you do a partner
why is a gobby to charity
junction tomorrow if you do that
cartwheel i died
this is
this is going to be brilliant i should
have ironed more than the front of my
shirt
and i'm swaying
[Applause]
oh okay here we go
how do you do a cartwheel oh
you do you know how to so just put your
arms up okay
so careful
[Applause]
yeah okay how am i going to get my legs
up in that farm
you're kicking me out no i don't mean i
don't i don't need to hit something
momentum is your friend yeah really why
did you put a banana on the floor
well i thought it must be picking up a
gun
i wouldn't run before you can walk
you you need a bit of momentum so you go
back there right and then look
so look so you're gonna run up here
right you're gonna put your hand there
and you're gonna your legs are gonna go
it's gonna be amazing they're gonna go
we're gonna slow it down you'll do that
and you're gonna go i think it's
possible
you've made me believe it is possible
okay here we go here we go here we go
is it that hand on the ground that hand
on the ground yeah
that hand on the ground kick that leg
for all your work yes for all your worth
okay
i know lucky me yes uh it's the
the two of you he plays a he plays a
congressman
and i play a contemporary bellow dancer
do you
yes yes he's a match made in heaven
yeah and you were doing lots of exterior
filming oh yeah which is actually a
problem when you're shooting with
someone like him because he's
vastly famous and wherever he goes
people are like
like they feel like their brains melt
you know when you look at someone's face
and you realize their brains just melted
when they see it
and we were having to do we had this
awful day we're having to shoot a very
emotional scene
lots of crying and you know begging
with each other where we're outside a
very public place and there are about
350 people
crowded around watching us do this
emotional scene that's mortifying
it's really really hard and so matt was
just managing to squeeze a tear out when
someone from the crowd went
murder
matt look to me he starts loving it this
is the worst day of my life